people have told me that as a director
you are very animated on the set you're
not you know hunched over looking and
then you quietly say a few things that
I've always for Woody Allen barely says
anything and that wasn't someone here
that you are acting stuff out and kind
of hyperkinetic is that right yes
unfortunate but true unfortunate because
there's me sitting here today and then
there's me who's on set which is like
everything about my self-awareness of
like oh I'd like to wear nice shoes all
right it's gone I'm just like whatever
it's gonna take to make this movie is
what I'm gonna do and in the behind the
scenes footage I'm like oh my god and I
know it at the time because later on you
saw hair is not washed and I'm where I'm
like and I'm like in sweatpants and on
the ground acting out a dying scene
because the quickest way for me to
convey to everybody is almost like being
a conductor I'm like okay and it's three
two and then down and and then we go you
know it's like whatever it takes if
that's the quickest way to tell the
actor that's how I'm shooting this this
is where and you're and then and then
the camera people are seeing it too and
great move on let's go like whatever it
takes I think there are two times in the
movie right so you accidentally get on
camera
didn't happen but I'll tell you what did
happen is that Chris and gal are such
beautiful wonderful people my dearest
favorite people
beautiful right and I would sit there
looking at the two of them and I became
them because of my whole day every day
I'm watching them and I'm like right of
course I'm them that makes perfect sense
yeah sure
day and night I watch them but then I
would go home and I would watch dailies
and I'd be like aha wonderful and then
all of a sudden one day someone like
half their size walked in and was like
okay guys that's great
[Laughter]
like a shocked yes I can imagine I've
experienced that many times when I I
catch myself during rehearsal Macbeth
we have a clip of Wonder Woman and this
doesn't this is just a tiny taste of
some of the amazing action anything you
want to say beforehand or would just let
it roll no this was an exciting moment
cuz it was sort of her first she's had
this wonderful achievement right before
and this is the first time she says this
is it I'm going to take over and do what
I can do so it's like almost a first
Wonder Woman moment let's take a look at
this clip from Wonder Woman
stay here I'll go ahead
[Music]
okay it's fun to see it every time
that's how you were doing it I enjoy
everybody else's work I have to ask you
before we wrap up here everyone's
thinking okay there's gonna be a sequel
are you gonna direct the sequel well
we're working on it
we're working on it I hope - I love it I
love the world and we all are really
excited about it okay if I can I'm very
powerful in this town if I can help get
that deal that's not funny
you